[soft piano music]
(Narrator)
Since ancient times,
we have sought to
know the human mind.
The first scientists
and philosophers
asked some of the same
questions we pose today.
[strings join in music]
What do we see, and why?
How do we learn,
and why do we forget?
Where do ideas come from,
and how do we
generate knowledge?
Human cognition is the basis
for our accomplishments,
[audience cheering]
yet understanding it
has proven elusive.
Learning more about
how we perceive,
how we think,
and how we engage with others
is one of the most important
endeavors of our time.
[music builds]
Yale can take us there.
The vision - a bold union
of scientific approaches
that lead to us to an
understanding of cognition.
Beginning with the
basic building blocks.
Genes, molecules, and cells.
Mental processes that
build to behavior.
Algorithms that lend insight
into the inner
workings of the brain.
Combine these components
with the diverse community
of scientists and scientific
interests at Yale,
and we can reveal the
capabilities of the mind.
We will understand how our
brains grow, change, and rewire
with the goal of
preserving and enhancing
the remarkable flexibility
of the human brain.
We will describe brain
function with new precision
using computational approaches
to map the contours of
perception, reasoning,
and memory.
We will marry disparate data
types to model human cognition
and advance
machine intelligence.
To discover deeper truths,
learn in new ways,
and teach a new generation.
The future of neuroscience
begins here.
To know, together.
♪♪
This is the Wu Tsai Institute
at Yale University.